محمد نظيف قادري مسؤول العلاقات العامه في
الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستانيه الايرانيه
المعارض شكرا جزيلا لك على قبول الحديث
معنا بكم
في برنامج الدعوه بالنسبه لموضوع الايران
ونشاطاتنا في داخل البلد
وحاله
نهزه الشعوب الايرانيه وخاصه مقاومه الشعب
الكلي في كردستان الايراني المظاهرات
الايرانيه بدات منذ اشهر وما زالت مستمره
الى غايه الان كيف تقيمون اليوم المظاهرات
في ايران حقيقه
مظاهرات الجديده في هذا فتره
بها فرق مع فترات الماس
وراء الاستشهاد
اخت
جيناء امينه ماسه
ثوره الايرانيه
في
حاله الجديد
وفي
اهداف
الخاصه وخاصه
تحت الشعار
مراه حياه وحريه
واهداف هذا السولى
اسقاط نظام الايراني
ونزال
لبناء النظام الديمقراطي
واتحادي وعلماني في محاوله من النظام
الايراني لقمح هذه المظاهرات يقوم بعمليات
تعذيب انتهاكات واحكام اعدام وحتى تنفيذ
بعض هذه الاحكام هل كنتم تتوقعون هذا
الموقف هذا الرد من النظام الايراني والى
اي درجه سيؤثر فعلا على حجم المظاهرات نحن
نعتقد على المظاهرات يستمر
اسباب الاستمرار لازم مظاهراتهم يعني
عزم السك مواطنين بالنظام
وسوء الاداره
وفساد في كافه الشؤون
السيستم النظام الايراني
جهات الامنيه وخاصه تدخلات المستمره الحرس
الثوري في كافه الشؤون الاداريه السياسيه
اقتصاديا وامنيا في بلد في حقيقه ايران
هسه سجن للمواطنين ولشعوب الايرانيه نظام
الايراني لا يزال يقوم
يعني على مواطنين للاعدامهم
كافه المجالات يحاول
يعني
ضغط على كافه
اخشار الجامعه مجتمع الايراني تتابعون ما
يجف المظاهرات الايرانيه الان اعدامات
احكام بالاعدام اعتقال تعذيب هل تفاجاتم
من طريقه تعامل النظام الايراني والامن
الايراني مع المتظاهرين ولماذا بقال نظام
الايراني حقيقه
ويرجع الى هذا السياسه الرخث واعتقال هذا
اذا احنا نشوف يعني حالات
واجهت النظام الايراني مع متظاهرين يعني
هم يقومون باسوا حاله تعامل مع متظاهرين
بنات
شباب
الجامعات حتى الشخصيات الدينيه
تشوف هسه في زاهدان في كردستان في منطقه
الاعواس النظام الايرانيه تهمكم بانكم
تقولون هذه المظاهرات من الداخل العراقي
كيف تردون على هذه التهم اتهامات النظام
الايراني يعني بعيد من حقيقه
نظام الايراني في شارع في مقاومه الشعوب
الداخل البلد يعني ما يقدر
يعني يقوم بعباده
حركه الجماهيريه
بس يتهمون الاحزاب وخاصه الاحزاب
الكردستان ومن راسهم حزب الديمقراطي
الكردستان الايران
ويعرف كحزب الديمقراطي اقدم حزب واقوى حزب
واندى يعني شعبيه خاصه في كردسان وحتى في
كافه المناطق الايران يعني حزب الديمقراطي
اهدافها اهداف الانسانيه اهداف للسياسيه
واهدافها بعيد من تطرف في 2016 كنتم
اوقفتم
حاله وقف اطلاق النار عدتم مره اخرى لكفاح
المسلحه والعمل المسلح اليوم من غير
الواضح ما موقف الحزب الديمقراطي
الكردستاني الايراني المعارض هل مستمرون
في حاله
الكفاح او العمل المسلح ام عدتم مره اخرى
لوقف اطلاق النار
حركه العسكريه
يعني في حاله
حاجه في اي وقت نحن نواجه الرياح تهاجم
اللزام الايراني في اي شكل من اشكال احنا
نقوم بالدفاع النفس دفاع النفس هذا حق
طبيعي من كل الناس ومن كل الجهات السياسيه
بس في وقت الراهن احنا نعتقد حركات مدنيه
حركات السياسيه جماهيريه وشعبيه
افزل تاريخ
لنزال ضد النظام الجمهوريه الاسلامي واحنا
نمشي على هذا خريثه وهذا التاريخ تاريخ
تاريخ سياسي تاريخ المدني وطريق النظام
السلميه زد النظام الايراني
ترحنا هذا الموضوع في
مجلس التعاون الاحزاب الكرديه واحنا في
حقيقه مع
احزاب المتحالف معنا في فندق الواحد زد
اللزام وان نعتمد على حركه سوريه شعبيه ما
الذي قد يدفعكم
لعمل عسكري من داخل العراقي او حتى
الانتقال والتسلل الى الداخل الايراني
يعني
في داخل العراق
ما عندي اي تواجد واي حلقه من حدود
العراقيه من حدود العقل من كردستان باتجاه
العراق كافه النزاراتنا
كافه الحركاتنا في داخل الكردسان الايران
وفي داخل الايران
وهذا اذهام المحس من لزام الايراني على
احزاب السياسيه الكرديه
في اقليم الكردستان احنا يعني
واجباتنا واجبات الثقافيه اعلاميه سياسيه
ومدنيه
في داخل البلد
يعني الشعب الكردي عند سياسي وهم يعرفون
بحقوقهم وينازلون من اجل تحقق الحقوق
ونزعم الايراني يخاف من هذا السوره ويخاف
من رئيس سياسي الشعب الكردي في ايران
والشعب الكردي في حقيقه يعني في
ختم مقدمه لهذا نهزل سياسيه في ايران وفي
كردستان
وفي
راي عام
راي عام الدولي يعرفون دور الشعب الكردي
والسياسه الحزب الديمقراط وحلفاء الحزب
الديمقراطي
وايزا نؤكد
وحزبنا يعني
على طريق السياسي يقوم
تقرير الحركه السوريه
ولكن النظام الايراني يهدد بعمل عسكري بري
ضدكم ضد الاحزاب الكرديه الايرانيه
المعارضه في هذه الحاله كيف ستتعامل مع
وضعك هكذا صحيح جزاء الايراني لا يزال
في داخل الكردستان الايراني
دفاع النفس حقنه
ونقوم الدفاع
وفي اقليم الكردستان ايضا ادم
مسؤوليه يعني
عمل يرجع الى مواقف الحكومه الاقليم وحكم
العراقيه وهذا عملا يعني
احتلال الارازي العراقيه من جانب الايران
هذا تهديدات واعتقد مجتمع الدولي لازم
يقوم بادانه السياسه النظام الايراني
وتعديلات النظام الايراني هل هناك اي جهات
داخل ايران داخل اجهزه الامن الايرانيه
تتعاون معكم في حقيقه احنا في داخل البلد
عندي اصدقاء
مشيتين السياسي مشيتين مدني وثقافي
وبشكل المباشر عندهم اتصال معنا
وحزبنا عند
تنظيمات
الواسعه في
كردستان الايران في باقي مدن الايرانيه
ولا يزال هم عندهم دور
ويرسلون الينا معلومات
واجتماعات لازم
استفاده منها للتعزيز الحركه السوريه
لتنشيط العمل
الشعبيه وجمال
هل تصل معلومات مثلا وما اهميه وقوه هذه
المعلومات في كافه المجالات
في داخل البلد
شرفاء يتعاونون معنا هذا اعتراف
هذا اعتراف بان لديكم جهات داخل الحرس
داخل الامن داخل استطلاعات التعاون معكم
كافه المجالات نحن عندي اصدقاء ويتعاونون
معنا كيف طريقه التعاون
باشكال المختلف ما حاجه احنا نحكي على
يعني كيفيه الاتصال بس يعني
منازلين
مناورين
واشخاص
نشيد في ساحه السياسيه
عندهم اتصالات معنا ومع التنظيماتنا في
داخل البلد
هذا واضح لا تريدون الحديث كثيرا عن
تفاصيل ولكن على الاقل الامن القومي موجه
الامنيه للاصدقاء بالضبط اكيد ولكن بل ان
القومي الايراني كيف
يمدكم بمعلومات ما اهميه المعلومات التي
تصلكم نوعيه المعلومات انا شخصيا ما اقدر
يعني تاكيد هذا اذاعه النظام الايرانيه
النظام الايراني متعامل بالكذب
واي وقت يريد تسويه لاي شخص يتهمون
بالعملاء السعوديه عملاء الامريكا عملاء
الاسرائيل وجهات الاخرى يعني
هذا السياسه الرسميه نظام الايراني اي وقت
يريد تشفيه واعدام اي شخص من اي جهه
يتهمون
بالاتصالات مع الدول
الاجنبيه وهذا
يحتاج دراسه الموضوع
وتحقيق حول هذا الموضوع بس انا عزوه الحزب
الديمقراطي الكردستاني ايراني في مقام
المسؤول ما اقدر
تسديق هذا الايراني هل يمكن ان الامر اي
علاقه
بصراع داخل اجهزه الامن الايرانيه صراع
متعلق بشمخاني
الشراع في
داخل النظام الايراني موشي جديد بس حاليا
يواصل الى اعلى حاله
صراع بين الحرس الثوري مع مجلس
مجلس
برلمان الايراني
صراع بين الحرس الثوري مع الجيش صراع بين
الحرس الثوري مع بيت
الخامنئي وشراء ايضا في داخل الحرس الثوري
وهذا واسع للكل ناس ووازع للكل الجهات
السياسيه
وامنيه يتابعون موز الايران بس خلافات
يتزايد
نتابع كذلك المواقف الدوليه جل الدول
الغربيه تتحدث عن ادانات تتحدث عن عقوبات
لا نعلم درجه تاثير هذه العقوبات على
النظام الايراني كيف تقيمون هذه المواقف
حسب
المتابعاتنا بالنسبه للاخبار
وتسريحات الدول الاوروبيه وحتى مجلس الامن
بالنسبه لموضوع الاستشهاد الجينه
ونشيطين ثوره داخل البلد
اعتقد دول الاوروبيه
وتنزيمات وملازمات
الدفاع عن حقوق الناس
مواقفهم جيد احنا نشكرهم
وايضا دول المنطقه دول المنطقه
مواقفهم بها فرق مع دول الاوروبيه وحتى
امريكا خاصه دول العربيه بالنسبه لهذا
اجرامات
جرائم النظام الايراني لا يزال احددون
الدول العربيه بالدرون تداخل من شؤون
البلدان العربيه شؤون الدول الاسلاميه
يعني تزود تجهيزا ميليشيات الموالي نظام
الايرانيه وخاصه الفيلق القدس في هذا
الدول يقومون بين يعني تداخل
الامنيه ويقومون باختيارات حتى
نشيطين السياسي جدا النظام الايراني
لحد
التوقعه يعني لازم
مجتمع الدولي دول المنطقه يعني اكثر منها
هذا حاله يعني
ادانه النظام الايراني
على نظام الايراني بالنسبه للجرايم
ماذا عن العراق هل تخشون مثلا ان تخرجكم
بغداد او اربيل من كردستان العراق ان
تبعدوا من الداخل العراقي
اوزح من الشمس هذا السياسه النظام
الايرانيه تدخل من بغداد
اشعار الاخواننا في بغداد وفي بصره خلال
الاسبوع المازي برا برا ايران بغداد
يعني مواطن العراق يعني
يقومون
بالمقاومه الزد التداخلات النظام الايراني
وعملاء الايراني وايضا في اربيل في كافه
الانحاء الشرق الاوسط تهديدات النظام
الايرانيه يعني واسع
ولازم مجتمع الدولي يقوم يعني
رد فعل على هذا تداخلات وهذا يعني
سياسه الفرز
سياسه الايراني على اراده الشعوب المنطق
نظام الايرانيه حاضر
وبس احنا
درسنا هذا
نحاول
نستمر على نزالنا وهذا شاي عاد وايداعات
النظام الايراني في بغداد وفي جهات الاخرى
مع جهات الاخرى يعني هذا مو اول مره لا
يزال هذا
سمعنا كان بس احنا في داخل الكردسان
الايران وفي جبال الكردستان وفي فنادق
في فنادق الفيشماريه نقوم ونقاوم ضد
العاده السياسه وان نبقى حركتنا حتى
انتصار من اين تحصلون على الدعم
شعبنا شعب الكردي اصدقائنا يقومون
بدعمنا
ماديا تجهيزيا عسكريا يعني احنا
يعني
نتمسك بنت الشعب واراده الشعبنا تدعمون
ماديا فقط ماديا وانا اخذ
مستلزمات النزالنا من الاسلحه
هذا سوق الاسود
ونشتري بالحمايه الشعبنا ماذا عن الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والدول العربيه هل
تحصلون على اي دعم من هذه الجهات لحد الان
ما اخذنا اي مساعده من دول العربيه ومن
حتى عياده المتحده الامريكيه
او الولايات المتحده الامريكي السؤال
الاخير ولكن
من شقه وجانب شخصي كنت تعرضت لمحاوله
اغتيال السيد محمد نظيف هل تخشى ان تتكرر
هذه المحاوله هل تشعر بامان في كردستان
العراق لا
يعني خلال
ثلاثه شهور الماضي احنا
ثلاث مرات من جانب النظام الايراني نواجه
بقصف الصاروخيه والدرون
واكثر من ثلاثه اشمن مقاتلنا استشهدوا
وعدد من
حوالي خمسين يفر من مقاتلين وعوائلنا
واطفالنا جرحوا
لا يزال احنا
نواجه بالتحديدات النظام الايرانيه بس
احنا
بايش مرقه
ومنازل ويعني
كفاحنا من اجل يعني تحقق الاهناف الشمع
شعبنا
نتحمل هذا تهديدات وختورات محمد نظيف
قادري مسؤول العلاقات العامه في الحزب
الديمقراطي الكردستاني الايراني المعارض
شكرا جزيلا لك فرصه سعيده شكرا اتمنى لكم
التوفيق